I'm great Santa from the president and
CEO of Julie and marine systems I am the
creator of the ghost boat we came up
with the name ghost because the boat is
intended to have no radar signature at
all the biggest challenge of the US Navy
today is how do you get in and operate
and deny access areas what today we
can't do it and that's what ghosts can
do ghosts can go in those areas loiter
for 30 days on fuel onboard and leave
without anybody knowing you're over
there our philosophy has been that we
will put up the risk money for our D
because that allows us more flexibility
and uses for the product later on you
just can't wait for the government to
say we want this you need to be
developing products like this Imbrium to
the government and saying look what we
have are you interested in this program
that's where we are right now this looks
this way purely to reflect radar but it
ends up looking cool everybody that sees
that thinks it looks like it's out of
Star Wars Star Trek and one of those
shows but it's really all functional
every angles very very functional
it's very easy to drive you haven't set
a gas turbine throttles those jet
engines and you have it steering
joystick and that's all you have to do
with this boat is push on the throttles
and move the joystick when you command
the boat to turn the computers know
exactly what they should be doing to
turn the boat a super cavitating
underwater structure means that you have
surrounded the entire underwater
structure and gas we can get about six
or seven feet of clearance between the
bottom of the command module in the top
of the way so we can actually cut
through waves without feeling that now
we're primarily focused today on the
defense segments internationally and
domestically but this whole forms a
great opportunity for sport fishing
boats for jet skis for high-speed boats
this technology can be employed in all
those different product lines